He served in World War
One and World War Two.
He's still one of Germany's most respected
military leaders and yet he never
even wanted to be in the military.
Who is this man that led the German
troops to victories but defined Hitler at
his own peril?
What made him who he is and what
keeps his name and the history books?
Well,
that's what we're looking
at in today's biographics,
the life of Erwin Rommel,
the Desert Fox
hold in Germany in 1891 oh when Rommel
half have the military in his DNA.
His father was a teacher and he was the
only member of his family to enter the
military as a career.
Obvious three siblings
that live to adulthood.
At one brother,
it became a dentist and other became an
opera singer and his sister became an
art teacher as a child role,
wasn't particularly athletic.
In fact,
he's even been described as frail,
but he hit his stride and his early
teens discovering sports and becoming a
leader among his peers.
Around this same time,
he also discovered his love of
mathematics and engineering.
He built his own glider and was known
to spend his free time taking apart
machinery and putting
it back together again,
a teenage rumble,
even dismantles and entire motorcycle
and rebuilt this now Robel he was clearly
intelligent,
but his grades,
they didn't reflect it
without good grades.
Rommel couldn't continue his education
at university with his talent for
machinery.
He considered working at a
factory near his childhood home,
but his father didn't
want him working that.
Instead,
his father pushed grumble
into military service.
At the age of 18 Rommel began studying it.
The officer Cadet School in Tokyo was
part of the 124 for Wurtenburg infantry
regiments.
He graduated in 1911 and by January
of 1912 was commissioned as second
lieutenants as a battery commander.
He became part of the 124
for Weingarten regiments.
He showed his military talent early on.
He was still a young men and it's no
surprise the rumble has more going on in
his life than just his military service.
Rommel had met a young woman by the name
of Walburga stenner while he was posted
in wine.
Gotten the two began and romance and wild
bagger rented up pregnant when rubble
the ends of her pregnancy.
You promised that they would marry and
live in a house and be a family before
they could marry.
Very wild dog gave birth to her
daughter that she named to Gertrude.
Months later,
Rommel stationed away from Weingarten
sent well bag or a letter the contained
far different news than what she expected.
The lesser broke the news
that he couldn't marry her.
She wasn't from the right class to be
an officer's wife and was Korea was his
priority.
Then there was the fact that he was
also in love with another woman.
The other woman was at Lucy Mollin.
She and Matt,
while he was in cadet school,
though they did not marry until 1916
rumbles a clear commitment to Lucy did not
stop Walberg out from loving him,
though she stayed
devoted to him for years,
believing that as long as he never
had children with another woman,
that was a chance that
he would return to her,
but he never did.
In 1928 Walburga lands that Lucy
was pregnant with Rommel's trials,
unable to deal with the news.
She killed herself.
Rommel and Lucy were supportive of
Gertrude both financially and emotionally.
They welcome time into their home.
They did introduce her as their niece
when Lawler was fighting in Africa.
The scarf that he wore was knitted for
him by Gertrude Rommel and Lucy's own
son,
man.
Fred was born in 1928 and even went
on to become mayor of Stuttgart for 20
years.
That's almost family
life was taking shape,
so was his military career months after
his illegitimate daughter was born in
world war one,
broke out role,
began his war service as a
platoon commander in Verdun
where he soon established
the fearlessness that he became
known for only a month into the war.
He'd charge degree for French
soldiers with a banner ads on his own.
He had no ammunition but the
French troops did rumble.
It was shot in the leg,
but this was only to be the first of many
injuries that he sustained during his
military service.
Rommel was so well known for charging.
It had an ending up in the thick of this,
this his trips used to see where Rommel
is there as the front [inaudible] served
in France,
Romania,
and SLE during World War One.
He was not only respected for his courage,
for his leadership and implementing new
strategies and maneuvers for warfare.
One of rumbles,
most exceptional victories came as he
led troops in the mountainous region of
Kappa rata in Italy.
Rommel streets where polyphasic
conditions were horrific,
but with the use of new
infiltration tactics.
The German Nan Austro-hungarian troops
had a decisive victory over the Italian
army.
9,000 Italian men were
captured 150 of them offices,
Rommel.
It didn't achieve this
by following orders.
It's quite the contrary.
In fact,
when he was told to stand down,
he moved forward and attacked.
He also used a strategy you have
coming out the attacks from surprising
directions and creating confusion and
disorder among the Italian trips for his
role in the battle,
Rommel received the Paul and Mary.
It's a prestigious German Order of merit.
Even before his achievements of the
Battle of Cup Hereso Rommel has earns the
iron cross and had been
promoted to first lieutenant.
In 1918 he received another promotion
to captain when World War One ended.
Rommel stayed in the military,
leaving the 30th infantry regiment and
still got most of the work involved
dealing with civil unrest,
but Rommel didn't use the same aggressive
tactics he was known for in the
battlefields.
In fact,
the avoided using force as much as he
could and negotiations took the place of
action in the town of Lindau
rather than attack the communists,
he was staging an uprising and the town
rumble used to diplomacy to get the
cities governments back under
control recognized for his leadership
capabilities.
Rommel was sooner pointed to two
teeth Shanthi Dresden infantry school.
Among the advice a Lawford future
military leaders is this advice that he
followed in his own military career.
Be an example to your men and your
duty hand in your private life.
Never spare yourself and let the troops
see that you don't in your endurance and
fatigue and privation.
Always be tactful and well mannered and
teach your subordinates to do the same.
Avoid excessive sharpness
or harshness of voice,
which usually indicates the man who has
shortcomings of his own to hide during
this time at Rommel also said to work
putting his military strategies on paper.
In 1934 Rommel Oseberg on
infantry training was published.
He was no longer teaching having left
that role in 1933 but he was leading
troops in gossip.
It was in Gossler that he encountered
at off it and for the first time Hitler
was chancellor and he was in
Gosselaar to inspect troops.
By 1937 Hitler was well
aware of Ronald Man,
his reputation.
He names Rommel,
the war ministry liaison
for the Hitler youth,
but Rommel was not a
member of the Nazi party.
He ends another hit.
The youth leader disagreed about tactics
and organization for the group and in
the end,
rumble lost his role in 1938 even though
Rommel wasn't a member of the Nazi
party,
he was still a supporter of
Hitler during his rise to power.
He did agree with Hitler's efforts to
re militarize and do unify Germany and
Hitler still wanted Rommel in the
upper echelons of the military.
In fact,
he made a direct request that rubble
will be part of the units that traveled
with Hitler.
The assignment not only gave
Rommel access to the fear,
but it also gave him more free time for
his hobbies and interests than he had
ever had before.
He wants again,
started focusing on math and engineering
and even took time away to go skiing,
but this wasn't a loss because war,
it was just around the corner.
1939 was a watershed year for Europe and
it's the wells under Hitler's orders.
Germany invaded Poland on September the
first 1939 as part of the preparation
for the invasion,
Rommel had been promoted to major
general and was entrusted with protecting
Hitler as war erupts says.
Then in 1940 Ronald was put in charge
of the seventh Panzer Division,
the Panzer divisions
made up of armored tanks.
Well,
an ideal opportunity for rumble to put
his particular strategic skill set on
display.
Initially plans were for rum olds who
heads up a mountain division first.
With the support Rommel was able to
land at the head of the division.
He wants it in addition to armored tanks.
Rommel was also leading rifle regiments,
a motorcycle battalion as an engineer.
The Talia,
Andy was doing this out of the usual order
of military protocol when Hitler made
Romola General.
He bypassed other more
experienced military men to do so.
This started some grumblings
within the German military,
but Rommel assume proved himself
to be worthy off the rank.
He puts his division through their
training pieces for months and in May they
sat off for battle and France.
The battle,
it didn't start out well
for ramen and an air strips.
Bridges were out where they needed to
cross a river and it's the French were
firing,
stopping the German troops
from making attempts to cross,
but Rommel outsmarted them.
He's our building's on fire creating a
wall of smoke that gave it strips the
cover they needed as they fired her
back across the river at the French.
They then got in rubber boots and
made their way across the water using
materials from another panzer division.
They built a bridge and the full
division moved across Rommel.
He wasn't standing back and giving orders.
No.
The general was actually in the thick
of the action firing a machine gun and
even wading into the water
to put the bridge together.
Once again,
Ramos Division made quick progress.
Within days they captured 10,000 French
soldiers and only lost three doesn't
have their own men.
For this victory,
Rommel was awarded the Knight's cross.
In the coming weeks.
Rommel continues has
advanced across France.
He announced success is to had learned
a telegram containing only four words.
I'm on the coast.
Throughout the seventh panzer
divisions move across France.
Rumble moved his trips so quickly in
surreptitiously that even the German high
command couldn't keep track of them.
This led them to debates the
ghost division off to the
gentleman's march through
France,
the stories a Roosevelt,
Rommel shooting,
an unarmed French prison off
and not following orders.
He's also been accused of involvement in
the massacre of French African soldiers
from Senegal and men under his command
were involved in the killing of dozens of
men who are surrendering and therefore
posed no threat to the German soldiers.
While some of his troops were very
likely involved in such a trustee's,
historians believe rumble would not have
given commands for such brutal attacks.
According to historian Rafael Shack,
although there is no
evidence incriminating,
Rama themself is unit did find in areas
where German massacres of black French
prisoners of war were extremely common.
In June,
1940 after the gym Taiko for France,
the plan it was at first for
Ronald's to had to Britain.
That would be the next nation
the Germany would take over.
But it was decided that the German air
force wasn't strong enough to do what
needed to be done in order to take over
England's and instead Rommel was sent to
Africa.
The Afrika Korps was a newly
created division of the
German military and General
Rummel was the man who
led it to victories.
The Italians had been suffering crushing
losses in northern Africa and Hitler
wanted the Germans there to beat back.
The British royal arrived in the in 1941
and he was supposed to answer to the
Italian commanding military officer,
but he disagreed with
the Italians tactics.
They wanted the Italian and German
troops to use a defensive strategy.
Rommel wanted to advance and take
on with the British directly.
Hedler agreed with Rommel man's
Rommel began planning an offensive.
The British,
however,
had no idea that was the plan.
The only intelligence
was the rumbles orders,
where to stay put.
When Romo moved districts forward,
they were caught a well off guard,
rumbles slimer nuvaring.
It's proved fruitful for him once again,
but even with success,
the Italian lead a
Garibaldi was not happy.
Rommel,
her disobeyed orders and
then matter the outcome.
That was not the way the
military was supposed to work.
However,
Rommel,
he had a response for Garibaldi value.
One can often,
they're two unique opportunities to sit
by for the sake of trifles outside of
Germany.
Rummel was capturing the
attention of world leaders.
Winston Churchill was 90 water.
What else matters?
But beating him,
but the nickname he owns it.
His clandestine maneuverings in Africa
is what a stuck through the decades of
history,
and I would be the Desert Fox,
but its successes.
They came to an ends.
The British recaptured,
the city of Tobruk and
rumbles games had been lost.
Then rumble was part of a crucial
meeting with Hitler Ins and other German
military leader elders,
Castle ring,
the two field marshals.
They disagreed and how the
Germans should move forward.
Initially they presented their arguments
and Hitler agreed with castle ring.
Gasser ring took over and Rommel was moved
to do need the troops on the coast of
France.
By the time Romo was reassigned to France,
he was starting to be more
and more skeptical of Hitler.
His strategies and his goals are almost,
didn't support the brutal actions,
the SS,
and eventually you came to believe that
Germany would be better off negotiating
an end to the war instead of continuing
the carnage and all the death,
and he wasn't alone in his beliefs.
A group of men who agreed with Rommel,
even suggested that he should
become Geminis new leader.
Though Rommel didn't
act on that suggestion,
the mere fact of the suggestion ultimately
helped seal rumbles face from the
time he was in charge of coastal forces.
In 1943 Rommel spent his time and
strategy building up coastal defenses.
He says mine's built barbed
wire obstructions and even
had troops flood areas of
the coast to make it
harder for trips to pass.
Three he also wanted to bring
more tanks closer to the coast,
better.
No one else agreed with them
that that was necessary.
In the summer of 1944 it would
turn out to there's Rommel,
well,
he was riced wants to move
more tanks to the coast.
On June the fifth 1944 Rummel left France.
He headed home to Germany so that he
could be with his wife on her birthday.
June the sixth when he left France,
he and the rest of the German military
thought the weather would be bad and they
didn't have to worry about any allied
movements on the coast and they also
thought that if any trouble was to come,
it would be a Kelly,
but the allies had used
the German military is weak
intelligence system to get
them to think that the
attack would come at Cali.
While he was a time celebrating
his wife's birthday,
Rommel received a phone
call that shocked him.
The allies had landed at
Normandy on June the SEC.
The weather had cleared and
the trips were storming.
The beaches rumbled left Germany
immediately to hand to the front.
He and other leaders establish
to counter attack plan,
but I live fire was too strong and
needed troops when table to arrive.
Rommel himself was injured badly by
allied air strikes and the ends 155,000
allied troops landed during the d day
invasion growing to 1 million after the
initial push,
the fourth stormed through German
defenses during the summer of 1944 it's a
rumble.
It was clear that jam and he couldn't
overcome the losses and so you continued
forward march of the allies.
He broke the news of his assessment to
hit not telling him the tape political
solution was likely the best way forward.
At this point,
the fear,
though he did not agree this meeting
would ultimately be the lost between the
two men as victory for Germany
was looking less and less likely,
opposition to Hitler
was growing in Germany.
High ranking military officials,
including those close to Rommel where
it's starting to make plans to get rid of
the Fiera assassination was among
the many options they contemplated.
Knowing Rommel disagreed with Hitler.
Runs was growing increasingly upset
with the fear of the men plotting to
overthrow.
Hitler tried to bring him into the fault.
To this day,
it's unclear ref.
Rommel was actually involved in a
plot to assassinate Hitler on us,
and if he was,
it's unclear just how much he knew.
His widow later said,
Rommel only wanted Hitler to be
brought to court and it's nothing more.
If you're a though he fought to,
there's a rumble,
wanted him dead and in the
end that's what matters.
I'm July 20th,
1944 a group of conspirators smuggled a
bomb inside the briefcase into a meeting
at Hitler's headquarters that
was supposed to be two bombs,
but there was only time to prepare
one and two when it exploded.
The survived instead of a successful key
with the conspirators found themselves
facing treason charges and the death
penalty and Rommel was among those
indicators.
In October,
1944 two or fitness generals confronted
rumble as ss troops surrounded the area.
The generals told Rommel that he had
three options and you could go to speak to
Hitler directly and explain himself and
he could go to court or he could commit
suicide there.
And then Rommel,
Molly opted for suicide in his
final communication with his wife.
He explains why in view
of my services in Africa,
I have the chance of dying by poison.
Two generals have brought it with them.
It is fatal in three seconds.
If I take the poison,
none of the usual steps will
be taken against my family.
That is against you.
They will also leave my staff alone.
Having explained to his
family what was to happen,
Ron more got into an ss car.
He took the Sinai Capsi,
all that Hitler's general
had brought and he died.
He was wearing his Africa corps jacket
and carrying his field marshal's baton.
The world was told he died of wounds he
had sustained from allied air attacks in
the wake of d day,
and he was buried with full military
honors only after the war did the truth
emerge.
Rommel was not maps with the
same disdain from world leaders.
There's other Germans were
in the wake of World War II.
Even Winston Churchill
spoke highly of him.
He also deserves our respect because
although a loyal German soldier,
he came to hate him and all his works
and took part in the conspiracy to rescue
Germany by displacing the
maniac and tyrants for this,
you paid the forfeit of his life,
uh,
when Rommel was a talented leader,
but his military duty survey regime that
had terrible intentions and committed
horrific atrocities were almost life and
death were intertwines with a watershed
era in human history.
An era upon which he left his mark.
So really have you found that video?
Interesting?
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and do not forget to subscribe.
We put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday.
Also check out some videos from the
archive over there on the right.
Also,
if you want to vote on
who we do on this channel,
please head over to our website and do
say there is a link in the description
below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.